deutschland ist eines kilos republik das
zeigt sich jeden tag und man ärgert sich
mal mehr mal weniger aber gestern habe
ich mich ganz besonders darüber
aufgeregt es ist etwas passiert was zum
letzten mal vor 16 jahren passiert ist
deutschland hat einen neuen kanzler
bekommen es gibt leute die haben gar
keine andere kanzlerin erlebt als vor
angela merkel und falls sie zufällig
gestern bei irgendeinem spartensender
geschaut haben ard und zdf haben ist
nämlich nicht übertragen dann hätten sie
mitbekommt da ist ein neuer im amt hat
weniger haare ein anderes geschlecht
olaf scholz und als die entscheidende
frage gestellt wurde im bundestag herr
scholz nehmen sie die wahl an da ist er
nicht aufgestanden da hat er nicht das
mikro an gemacht dass er von vorn
gerutscht und hat gesagt ja vermutlich
hat er ja gesagt ich hab's nicht gehört
er hat ja damit aber der stillosigkeiten
nicht so nicht zu ende es gab danach
noch eine verabschiedung von vor angela
merkel durch die junge union durch die
union parade durch die union und er
wollte ja ziemlich gefragt was denn vor
merkel bekommen habe und die antwort
bekam was man halt so macht ein strauß
blumen und eine flasche wein auch das
ist stillos heute da die verabschiedung
das weiß die neue übernahme des
verteidigungsministeriums durch vor
lamprecht frau kramp karrenbauer war
nicht anwesend sie war verärgert
aufgrund personeller rochaden auch das
ist stillos und um noch einmal zum
abschluss in den bundestag zu kommen was
hätten andere länder den gemacht wenn
sie einen neuen kanzler oder einen neuen
präsidenten bekommen hätte da wird die
trikolore in den himmel projiziert
worden da hätte man pomp and
circumstance aufgefahren und in
deutschland wird nicht einmal die
nationalhymne gesungen ich finde das ist
ein wenig ärmlich es gibt auch so etwas
wie republikanisches pathos es gibt auch
so etwas wie eine leidenschaft für
demokratie und wenn wir demokraten haben
wollen die leidenschaftlich für die
demokratie ins feuer gehen dann müssen
wir auch unsere demokratischen hochfeste
zelebriert und wie es ihnen angemessen
ist gestern war ein solches hochfest und
was haben wir stattdessen gesehen
verwaltungsakt
dienstes news grauer mehltau aller orten
nur neues personal dasselbe trauriges
stück nein nein nein wir brauchen etwas
mehr republikaner paters großartig ich
bin durch steigerungssatz
das kommt auch natürlich aus den
handelnden personen
wer selber kein stil hat kann auch eine
stillose republik nicht auflösen also
ehrlich wenn man heute abend olaf scholz
gesehen hat wie er da vor sich hin
geflüstert hat und irgendwas gesagt hat
was keinen zweck erkennen lassen hat
dann stelle ich mir immer wieder die
frage gibt es überhaupt noch in
deutschland einen einzigen politiker
politikerinnen der eine vernünftige gute
konzipiert rede halten kann ohne sie
wort für wort vom blatt zu lesen der
länder ist ein guter reden ja das stimmt
schon manchmal ja der brinkhaus
eigentlich wenden schreibt jedenfalls
die kanzlerin hat ja jedes wort
abgelesen sogar wenn sie sagt ich danke
ihnen und verabschiede mich ist jedes
wort abgelesen gewesen und
aufgeschrieben worden und das ist bei
schlafes bruder auch so und die drei die
heute da zusammen saßen sind alle von
der gleichen sorte also woher kommt wie
soll ich sagen wer bläst das
republikanische feuer an in diesem land
das problem das kann das kann lindner
auch nicht dass dafür rechts nichts ist
keiner da einsatz noch und es heißt ja
immer ein neuer stil würde jetzt ein
ziel mit der ampel das ist leider
ästhetisch und was die übereinstimmung
von form und inhalt angeht überhaupt
nicht ein kleines beispiel noch muss ich
leider sagen nein robert habeck der
durch das aufgrund sympathische züge hat
er stand dann erst mal falsch bei seiner
vereidigung wusste nicht aber nach
rechts nach links gehen kann die
krawatte hing schief und am tag vorher
am tag vorher haben wir im fernsehen
erfahren dass er ja in einer
fürchterlichen lage sich befinde er habe
seit zehn tagen nicht mehr abgewaschen
und seit fünf tagen nicht nur die
kleidung gewechselt und das an dem tag
bevor wirtschaftsminister werden wir
gedanken tragen hättest du doch
geschwiegen wärst politiker geblieben
ich finde ich das problem ich hab jetzt
ein ganz anderes problem ist dass du
dich überhaupt kein thema doch dann oft
ein thema opel das ist ein thema das
kann man keinen satz mehr sauger in
dieser saison
die politiker wie an einer katholischen
messe im wort ich kann sich da irgendwo
groß inszeniert das finde ich jetzt
nicht das thema das ist eine
sachlichkeit die dazu machst du kommt
und da sage ich aus schweizer oder
republikaner sage ich dass deine schönes
afrika wir brauchen doch nicht mehr
portos in der politik wir brauchen
vielleicht mehr ihren in der politik das
problem diese regierung ist ein ganz
anderes
das aufgefallen sind alles akademiker
das sind anwälte
sozialwissenschaften philosophen ihr
habt keinen einzigen minister der eine
berufslehre gemacht hat das heißt das
ist eine regierung die sich mehr oder
weniger 100 prozent von der eigenen
lebenserfahrung jenseits der
lebenswirklichkeit des großteils diese
bürger bewegt und das finde ich
eigentlich ein thema hier das café
radeland auch
optische bezug auf ihre bis in die
sachlichkeit im vordergrund steht und
nicht das pathos ist nur das ist für
mich geradezu ein durchbruch der
ehrlichkeit und redlichkeit dass man das
nicht über
inszenieren erfüllen das dass man das
nicht übrigens zenit aber wo ist der
praxisbezug diese woche hier aber
ehrliche entschuldigung wenn der scholz
nicht einmal aufstehen kann und sagen ja
herr präsident ich nehme die wahl an
frau präsidentin sonntag frau
präsidentin sondern rutschte und her und
man versteht es nicht vermuten er hat
jetzt gerade ja gesagt wenn eine
staatskrise nein gesagt hat die
scheidende und das grundproblem ist doch
dass wir das da keine übte praxis haben
wir hatten 2006 hat war dass das hat
wird ein erweckungsrat dass er plötzlich
frei wieder unsere nationalhymne singen
meisterschaft sommermärchen ich habe
selbst erlebt ich hatte wirklich immer
ein komisches gefühl wenn irgendwelche
menschen hinter mit deutschland
deutschland gilt gesungen oder blühe
deutsches vaterland stehe aufstehen
yorckstraße s bahn zwei züge fahren
fahren eine hinter mir singen plötzlich
ein großer chor die nationalem ich drehe
mich um und lauter junge leute hatte
tränen in den augen die erste generation
die das wieder kann und wir müssen das
in der politik auch lernen ich war
gestern im deutschen bundestag und stand
am tag der warum ist die veranstaltung
zu ende und nationalhymne ganz einfach
und natürlich muss man sich aus
schmücken das muss nicht katholisch
beendet aber das ist das hochamt der
demokratie und da muss etwas mehr
dazugehören stil anstand und auch ein
bisschen inszenierung es muss sich
amerikanisch werden da muss kein popstar
sinkt aber irgendetwas hat gestern
gefehlt und irgendwie niederlande oder
irgendwie ein bisschen pathos und ein
bisschen auch einfach dass wir als
nation auch sagen dastehen unsere
volksvertreter wir haben sie gewesen
sind die repräsentanten des deutschen
volkes und die dürfen auch gefeiert
werden und das ist für uns alle die
haben sie gewählt und sie sollen uns
regieren und dann dürfen sie auch
ordentlich ins amt eingeführt werden das
danach wieder die diskussion kam jimmy
jimmy smith hat losgefahren aber die
anderen mit in limousinen ja herrgott
nochmal ja die dürfen mit den limousinen
fahren die dürfen große autos fahren der
bundeskanzler muss fast schon mercedes
waren und die anderen die großen audis
und was wir noch alles herstellen das
gehört einfach dazu
wir sind repräsentanten und einsatz hat
mir gestern richtig deute denken gegeben
das war der satz von olaf scholz vater
die natur kollegin angelika hellemann
gesagt hat ich habe drei söhne alle drei
sind erfolgreich und der bundeskanzler
verdient am wenigsten auch da muss man
dann wenn wir nicht mal sagen dass der
bundeskanzler der wirklich und egal wie
man zu der politik steht das ist ein
knochenjob die journalisten die den
hinterher hier müssen fallen tot aus dem
flugzeug
knapp über 20.000 euro ja und ich finde
es nicht angemessen
es ist ein knochenjob und wirklich da da
hat man mehr verantwortung als ein
klinikchef man darf es nicht immer gegen
dann auf ihn aber sie müssen in der lage
sein ja zu sagen auch zu so etwas zu
mehr geld und vor allem auch zu passiert
ja nix am stil
losigkeit fängt ja beim
bundespräsidenten an also der versucht
ja immer stil darzustellen seit dem amt
ist ich habe den kopf nie so gemacht wie
nach seinem ausscheiden aus diesem amt
denn der hat noch wirklich originelle
reden halt noch selbst gedacht statt
denken zu lassen und diesen einen
nachfolger im präsidialamt sieht man
ständig beim anzünden oder ausblasen von
streichhölzern er ist an kerzen zugange
um irgendetwas zu bedenken das ist nun
ein missverständnis von stil dass es
auch ein missverständnis von
republikanischer tradition und das fängt
ganz obenan mit diesen mit diesem
merkwürdigen versuch irgendwas
darzustellen was er nicht ist und setzt
sich nach unten fort man hat eben auch
gestern gesehen dass man den eindruck
hat ist doch ein letztes fremde noch da
mit diesen institutionen die ja nun neue
repräsentanten gefunden haben und diese
eben zu richtig vertreten uns alle und
für die gewählt haben oder nicht es war
eine demokratische und es war eine
friedliche machtübergabe verdammt noch
mal es ist eine errungenschaft von
selber ja manchmal freuen da kam mal
stolz drauf sein und das kann man auch
mal ich muss gestehen zahlen deutlich
überragen wir stehen uns alle
gegenseitig den roche nach mal seine
rede an seine kinder einfach schön
kann jetzt dass das emotionale
engagement nicht ganz nachvollziehen
natürlicheres gestürzte gesagt hat dass
sie doch nicht mal die nationalhymnen
und gewinne aber wieder ein wenig also
da haben wir jetzt aber für eine
ausnahmsweise 100 richtig hören oder im
land das hatte eine nationale berichtet
man schon nicht mehr gesungen darum gebe
ich die war richtig so
ich sage einmal der stil ist schon
wichtig aber ich glaube in der heutigen
zeit ist noch wichtiger aus der stil ist
der inhalt das was sie machen und was
sie sind und man darf sich dann auch
nicht blenden lassen es gibt große ob
die gehen hallo und drang ja es gibt
großartige eloquente politiker die in
der ganzen herrlichkeit ihrer
rhetorischen ausweisungen sich da
präsentieren können warum er nach diesen
fünf mal am ende des tages muss man
immer schauen was unten rauskommt und
deshalb wenig an sachlichkeit die
nüchternheit ist für mich etwas was
sympathisch ist an der deutschen politik
aber die nationalhymne da gebe ich ihnen
recht die gehört dazu liefern auch die
unglücklich gelaufen den gottesbezug das
hat mich irritiert aber wohl auch schon
einen gottesbezug gemacht hat aber ich
hatte p lang eingeschlossen sondern für
mich hat das etwas tröstliches wenn ein
politiker in einer rede einen
gottesbezug hat weil dauernd weiß ich
akzeptiert noch eine autoritative sich
seine frau und den lieben etwas hat eine
spezielle hamburgische tradition hamburg
ist zutiefst republikanisch da reagiert
man nicht mit gott und
dann nimmt man noch keine ordner an im
übrigen hamburger politiker nehmen keine
orden nach helmut schmidt trafen ich
glaube da hat er nicht gemacht nur
schritte und schoss den gottesbezug in
ihren antrittsreden für mieten schmidt
schon aber das müssen wir auf jeden fall
dass er aus der kirche ausgetreten ist
ja legitim
nächste woche freitag der machen wir
nämlich die spezial sendung mit den
stammgästen die beiden werden bis
nächste woche freitag das versprechen
das recherchiert haben den fall bringen
die beiden uns hier mit